Michael Strahan Good Morning America
co-host also executive producer of
religion of sports on audience Channel
239 works for Fox and he's a
hall-of-famer and he joins his day he's
got his own clothing line to look at you
Mike look at you you're a mogul I know
it now that's all a surprise you went
right by me your beer Usain Bolt you
just blew right by me absolutely not you
know answering turn around you know I
was wondering about this with your
career and this is a good segue because
we're seeing Greg Olsen with Carolina
getting in the booth on a bye week for a
game with Minnesota and the Rams Tony
Romo gets in and maybe a year early
Cutler thought about it Jesse Palmer
Tiki Barber what was your strategy
because I look back on that last year
with the Giants you played 15 or 16
games had eight or nine sacks and could
have played another year but how
important was it to get in a year early
into broadcasting as opposed to a year
later a year early I played 15 years so
and out the 15 season and once we won a
Super Bowl
I had nothing else to prove so it was
time to move on
and I tried to squeeze out a few more
years but I didn't guys was in a lack of
hope you get some young players so I
just wanted to get out when we were on
top because it had been a magical season
and everything after that it was who
says when your football career is over
means your life is over it doesn't it
means really in a lot of ways just get
sorry so I love everything I do now and
I attack it the same way I attack
playing football and everything's been
working out and the right way for me
also when you look at your former team
the Giants and I know people have used
the word quit and that's probably the
toughest word that you can attach to
somebody that they quit can you look at
the Giants objectively and say if
anybody has quit in the last couple of
weeks
what definitely look at it and say that
there are times you go yeah it looks
like some guys quit it looks like some
guys are giving their max effort so we
had to be objective and honest
absolutely
but there are times if you watch the
game you go okay you know like they have
a camp look like they're together but
then it looks like all hope is lost
after one bad thing happens there are
two bad things happen and those are the
type of thing I've just had a lot of the
team's discord over there your players
getting suspended for various reasons
key players and when you're not winning
all those problems need to be magnified
when you're winning you kind of push
stroke problem who brings to the side
because you're winning games and when
you're not winning games I was happy and
all those things kind of you know be it
magnified and come through for your life
do you think been McAdoo's an NFL head
coach is a great coordinator I haven't
played for I haven't been around him
enough to really be able to make that
assessment I think last year when he
made game everyone definitely thought a
head coach and when you lose Game one
think you know what you're doing it
regarding it overnight which we know you
haven't found him enough to say yeah
he's wrong coach and I just hope that we
can get this thing turned around because
after playing this 15 you know of course
I'm a Giants fan and I don't want any
see anybody lose their job but at the
same time this is not the team that
everyone expected to see with this
record when the season started do you
think Eli Manning and his career as a
giant oh absolutely
oh you better not let he like or
anywhere else I think that this I think
he like a fantasy of his career the
other giant ie the Giants type of going
back to Super Bowls and I know everybody
better offensive line performance in a
there this year at points and I think
you got a great quarterback when a
quarterbacks are hard to find it's not
going to be you know he's not a Carson
26:5 that he can get out of stuff and he
can run he's
he's not that you knew what you were
getting good Eli when you drafted him
and what he's given has been successful
that's two Super Bowls about this a
matter of you know finding that right
formula but pleasured around him elevate
his game in the right way talking to
Michael Strahan it's got a few things
going on the religionist Sports tonight
at 8:00 Eastern and Pacific that's
available an audience channel 239 as he
partners with Tom Brady the
award-winning filmmaker Gotham Chopra
and takes you around the world to
examine untold stories of sports LeBron
James is getting into this now now I
know that you're involved in a lot of
different things but getting into being
a producer executive producer and how
important is that with the resume for
you I love it you know it's creative
it's creative and I get to be finally on
the same team with Tom Brady so that
helps in the wheelhouse so it's
something we go around the world and
tell stories about sports let's cover
business for it because it sports are
like a religion when you feed Houston
from one of the World Series it really
meant a lot this experience to everybody
impact that stadium to celebrate
together and the worship that victory
together to the players who are idolized
to the stadium where they go with just
like the temple and we can around the
world to tell these stories that are
bigger than sports is like experience of
what people are going through takes them
to a higher level and we do everything
from fencing's voice you would probably
nine from sensing to and as an overseas
there's a soccer team from refugee that
gives them a friends and family when
they have to leave their country and
leave their friends and family to prison
baseball at San Quentin so it's all
these things that give people through
sports some kind of experience that is
outside of that realm or outside of the
be be in a kind of a godly type of round
it's a lot of fun to be creative and I
think just natural and I think LeBron
does great work as well and so I see
other guys who's getting into this
business
Michael is one of eight players in
history with at least a hundred sacks
and at least to pick sixes for
touchdowns did you realize that yeah I
did not know that I had no idea but glad
you just tell my kids that daddy used to
be something wait now who did you
intercept but you had two touchdown
returns I in the Eagles game in overtime
and the interception and also the
Washington Redskins game I brought to
the cupboard undercut to tidy and at
home in New York and yeah you never
forget them like I could I could replay
those plays and like yesterday man you'd
never forget that stuff
Julius Peppers has a hundred and
fifty-one sacks and four picks an
amazing amazing
I mean Julius Peppers of the guy how he
and I talk about all the time this Duty
I looked at Julius Peppers and I think
man if I could only have been that
athletic and that size and a lot of guys
who have those those type of measurables
they don't live up to the height because
a lot of them have always gotten away
would just kind of be at Vegas has a
strong and game has kind of gone easy
for them and they don't play that long -
Julius Peppers as with Julius better has
taken advantage of all of his physically
dish
I marvel at the way that he still
performs now all these years in a league
but he's an amazing amazing player and I
had a chance waving them some Pro Bowls
and I've always enjoyed being around
it's a great guy before I let you go let
you plug your your luggage line you have
a clothing line now a luggage line well
you know I have a clothing line
collection for Michael Strahan also mfx
I'm at jcpenney and now we just start
out a next category Lewis categories
luggage and there's a snapper for me
yeah I travel every weekend I'm on the
road to LA so the natural extension of
something that I use every weekend and I
made it lightweight and affordable which
is always important for everybody and
it's something I think everybody's gonna
enjoy I'm gonna send you some man makes
me taken care of what color you have two
colors they're black we have grey
you know I'll send you whatever you want
I'll make sure that you'll avoid and get
around
pretty easily next time with all of your
possessions I like you know black will
be great but here's my question for you
Mike is do you have a piece of luggage
big enough to put Jay Glazer in it oh
yeah we got we make small luggage too oh
you do okay I said there are three there
are three sizes we can fit Jay in the
smaller size hey good luck with all of
this
always great to catch up with you Mike
thanks for joining us as always I got my
Michael Strahan for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]